وعلى
ازواجيه
سيدنا محمد و ازوار سيدنا
محمد وسلم
تسليما كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله الا الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا اله الا الله
لا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد
على انصار
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وسلم تسليما كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
ولله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله بكره واصيلا
لا اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا اياه
مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما كثيرا
براذ سستر السلام عليكم عليكم السلام
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام ورحمه
‏we need your entus
andery to at least in the
তাবিরা right so pleas do that also want
make cle of quick announ
you
mak we have me colction avilable at both
at aba mask and here so fre are
available the me ‏and distribute to the
families also there is after the prayer
there will be
the food breakfast is available pleas jo
us for that and please make sure your
children are hanging around here so we
have some also for the children
distribute that after the after the
prayers please continue with enthusasm
the for more minutes insall
صلاه have been some people asking the
question is there is both locations here
and aba mask so that's pray that need to
bect soct at لوكيشن
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم زم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
محمد وعلى انصار سيدنا
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره واصي
لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين ين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد
وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا
محمد وسلم
تسليما كثيرا.
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد السلام
عليكم امام حسن يزلام
‏we going go ahad and
start can you pleas br stand ups and the
and also
the pleas you the me at thisationশ
atফমা mask on the
fthশ and
‏pleas pleas
انء
الله حسين حط
[Silence]
‏So
insallah start the salah just coule of
minutes. ‏Let me take a moment insallah
to explain the way we be reading salid
insallah.
حبنا
تكبي
تكبير الله
اكبر
تكبي
فاتحه
سجود الله
اكبر تكبي
‏regبيرات
[Silence]
‏notلاصلاه
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
ان
‏usually is
[Silence]
some
استعتد between الله سبحانه مرسي
امين الله اكبر الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم
الله سبح اسم ربك الاعلى
الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من
يغشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم
ربه
فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله والتين
والزيتون وطور
سينين وهذا البلد
الامين لقد خلقنا
الانسان في احسن
تقويم ثم رددناه اسفل
سافلين الا الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات فلهم اجر غير
ممنون فما يكذبك بعد
بالدين اليس ليس الله باحكم
الحاكمين الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
ولله الحمد لله
[Silence]
‏Before I get started on the have a kind
request for the sisters. If you guys
want to do greetings, please step
outside in the hallways. ‏Brother and
sisters, if you guys don't want to sit
down, listen to pleas st outside.
[Silence]
الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره ونعوذ
بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مذل له ومن يدلله فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صفي
بخلق وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه
ونسح الامه وكشف الله تعالى به غمه وجاهد
في الله حق جهاد حتى اتاه اليقين اما بعد
فقال الله سبحانه وتعالى في القران المجيد
فرقان حميد بعد قول اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا ايها
الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ثم اما بعد ان
اصدق الكتاب كتاب الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر امور
محدثاتها وكل وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه
ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار ربي اشرح لي
صدري ويسر لي امري واحلل عقده من لساني
يفقه قولي اللهم لا سحل الا ما جعلته سحلا
وانت تجعل الحزن اذا شئت سحلا ولا حول ولا
قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم الله ربنا
وفقتنا ورجاؤنا ومولانا فنعم المولى ونعم
النصير الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله والله اكبر ولله الحمد alles
belong to الله سبحانه
وتالى magnificence and we thank him for
keeping alive one more day on the path
اللهcept
امين
الله
عرف عرف الله
‏sister
مصل
[Silence]
عليه الله سبحانه
وتعالى الاضحى
‏Now we cann
about anyas
of
all of himself
and everyle time go
[Silence]
امين مروه
‏until
now
sy
didى not only the
bless there
notlight
over that
حجره عليه الصلاه
والسلام ابراهيم عليه الصلاه
والسلام
ابرايم the
chransis and musl their lineage back
tobah andight about
‏are
so blessing
الله wasم اسماعيل عليه الصلاه
والسلام يرفع بيت الله
المحرم الله سبحانه وتالى ربنا تقبل منا
‏askcept
on weah
[Silence]
حج الله سبحانه
وتالى
اللهم يا
اللهر بوادي غير زرع
ابراهيم عليه
والسلام
bless and
food so you go to masallah you have the
best of the fruits available in the
entire world there some of the most
tastiest food you will have fruits you
have is in the meah
لبيك اللهم لبيك لبيك لا شريك لبيك ان
الحمد والنعمه لك والملك لا شريك لك الله
سبحانه
وتالى ان شاء
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى ابراهيم عليهلام
‏as
noter الله
ابراهيم
allah over and over and over and over
again and putم
عليه he
came a person who wasm
on a man who go ‏and the trouble in his
household with his
father and his father tells him to leave
the house. He leaves the house. He's out
by
himself and then they build a fire for
him.
‏him andous trials and tribulations and
no عليه tells him to
mar you how much you
[Silence]
لبيك الله سبحانه وبشرناه بغلام
حليم حليم
الله سبحانه
وتالى ابراهيم عليه
والسلام
whether برما
سودان
يمن شام غزه
فلسطين غزا سودان
[Silence]
আল্লাহ সুতা
அ
[Silence]
‏and sister
out their children are killed in front
of
them
are محمد رسول
‏any we have a
comm
wasecut while was
bn a col grate just got mared starting
the
life what we call the honey moon peri
‏are those are people الله سبحانه
وتالى you know we get one sh and one
push in the way of Allah and it done
with
over you know people go for and you know
they get coule ofs for three people
theirol that's it and people are being
punished
ابو بكر رضي الله عنه اتقتلون رجل يقول
ربي اتقتلون رجل يقول
ربي قريش
[Silence]
‏and so understand
this the legacy that we are
chasing most of us are chasing if you
tell me brother I don't not ching a
legacy we all are we all
‏areacy knowingly or
unknowingly that legacy has to be
determined for what cause it is and for
who it
is because we have a legacy of the sa
and
the how many of us here can say we
methيم عليه الصلاه والسلام n of us did
we see ابراهيم
اسماعيل عليه الصلاه
والسلام حج
[Silence]
عمره الله سبحانه وتالى
سف واذ ناديناه يا
ابراهيم
الله عرش الله يا
ابراهيم اللهم
[Silence]
‏name how people come beforey
ابراهيم عليه الصلاه
والسلام عليه
والسلام عليه الصلاه والسلام رسول الله
صلى الله عليه
انبياء الله سبحانه وتالى
are so take as badge of
today not away from being a true musl
and stand firm on the ground of
Allah اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
والله اكبر والله اكبر ولله الحمد اقول ما
تسمعون استغفر الله لي ولكم سائل المسلمين
كل ذنب فاستغفرنا ان الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
‏My take for you all today it's a day of
celebration not only
that the three days that we have are the
most greatest days
any after
the only day that you cannot fast is the
first day of
‏after the recommended not to fast 3
days. Allah says do not fast those three
days because Allah is making you a he
making you a guest to enjoy the
celebrations around
you. But as we go today forward to
celebrate with our family, our friends,
children
understand there is another side of the
Muslim that is starving, that is not
have shelter.
‏I often ask by me no means take take
as for anybody here any else I always
get asked are you today we are I always
do it every year we just chose to not do
it in the USA
‏me
days any more
me people who are do not get blessed
enough this might be the only they get
to eat something as you go for
you remember those who are less
fortunate you
areث and if a person comes asking you
for
‏as
bless and
around this one
more
yes حديث رسول
حديث inrund
‏not 10 minut away about may hour of
travel time may overn travel to come
attend right that was the main idea
that's why when you travel to a lot of
the
musl maority count you have a masjid
‏where there a masjid with huge
courtyards soing all the will close for
that day and everybody will gather in
one
spot and as
such
the was meant to be for the brothers and
the sister who had come from far
away to attend
the by the way those have first صلاه
third was
only
was so travel from far away and a lot of
people to go back to their houses for
provision there no there no food and
availability and that was given to a
specific group to not attend for some
the is for everybody and you take it as
it is my personalation would be for you
guys to pleas
الله سبحانه
وتالى عليه الصلاه
والسلام صلاه العصر المغرب يوم
الجمعه الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله عصر
المغرب الله سبحانه
وتالى
ان
برما ان غزه ان فلسطين ان شام ان
يمن سودان
[Silence]
‏aven الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى جالى
اللهم لا تدع ذنبا الا غفرته ولا هما الا
فرجته ولا كربا الا نفست ولا دينا الا
قضيته ولا مجاهد في سبيلك نصرته ولا عدوك
الا احلقت ولا ضالا الا هديته ولا اولادا
الا اصلحته ولا عيبا الا سطرت ولا حاجه من
حوادنيا لك رضا لنا قضيتها ويسرتها لنا
اللهم كان رزقنا في سماء فانذله ان كان
رزق في الارض فاخرجه وان كان بعيدا فقربه
وان كان قريبا فيسره وان كان قليلا فكثره
وان كان كثيرا فبارك لنفيه واعلم ان الله
قد امركم املا بذى في نفسه وثلى ملائكه
القدسي وثلى بكم معشر مؤمن جن عنس قال عزا
قائم عليما ان الله وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا تسليما اللهم سلم وبارك عنهم على
عبدك محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
عباد الله ان الله يامر ان الله يامر بعدل
واحسان وتائذي القربى فشاء ملك بغي يعيزكم
لعلكم تذكرون اذكروا الله العظيم يذكركم
واشكره ويزدكم واستغفره ويغفر لكم عيدكم
مبارك تقبل الله منكم سحل الاعمال والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم مبارك
‏You ان شاء الله تبارك الله